what's up everybody I'm Drew and I'm
Alex We Are The Chainsmokers and we're
about to play Truth or dab
[Music]
hey what's going on and welcome back to
another exciting episode of Truth or dab
the hot one special where we give our
guests two simple options tell the truth
or suffer the Wrath of the last app and
today I'm very excited to be welcomed by
Drew and Alex the Grammy award-winning
Duo better known as The Chain Smokers
they've been topping the Billboard
charts with hit after hit for close to a
decade and you can check out their
latest single up and down with 347 8N
streaming now Drew Alex welcome to the
show you got a great radio boy this is
like you just transformed
yeah so in front of you you guys have
the set of wings that have all been
doused in various versions of the last
dab I have a set of deeply personal
potentially awkward questions for each
of you and when I ask you a question you
have a choice answer it honestly or
escape the truth by eating a Deathwing
and Drew we're gonna start with you oh
is your day one fans know your origin
story begins as an intern at Interscope
here you are years later a rugged
veteran of the music business in your
experience and opinion which industry
practice this is the most anti-artist
while a lot of
you know labels now are so data driven
and I understand it like they can see
you know Trends happening songs that
could pop off quicker than ever why
wouldn't you use that but
um I found it becomes it just feels very
unmusical it's just so hard to predict
like an artist's career also often just
like data you know they could have
something that's working and
um you know there should be some people
that take longer to develop and they
just you know might not get that shot
because uh I don't know if they're not
having a viral moment or something so I
cringe a little bit when I hear people
talk about data but I also understand it
right right well we were talking about
before eventually we're just all going
to be AI yeah totally yeah all right
well that actually the topic of
conversation actually segues nicely in
my question for you Alex now when we had
Olivia Rodrigo on the show she talked
about her disdain for vocal chops what
do you know it's like our bread and
butter
what to you is the most insufferable
Trend currently going on in pop music
bonus points if you can give a main
culprit it's funny because like uh I
would say like the sped up pitched up
versions of songs like I I honestly like
I credit all of her troops I think it
sounded great I miss you but also I
blame him for the trend starting so yeah
I think I go with that not every song
needs to be sped up 40 BPM and pitched
up and I do love that that all that song
is Big yeah that sounds great now and we
love it I blame him
well there we are through the first
round so far you're gonna become harder
than that no wings off the table
Drew let's go to you for this one okay
Diddy recently made headlines for joking
that he owes sting five thousand dollars
per day for the rest of his life after
sampling the hit song I'll Be Missing
You what's the biggest hoop you've ever
had to jump through in order to secure a
feature or sample biggest hoop we've had
to jump through
what would you say
uh well I mean we've jumped in many
Hoops well this is your question
he's like I'm not gonna save you
um
well I mean for closer which like almost
I would say a lot of our biggest songs
almost didn't happen you know Camila
Cabello is originally singing on that
song and we had already like kind of
debuted at Coachella and our Twitter was
going crazy about it and then she
decided the song wasn't for her and we
were in this like panic mode we were set
like you know six weeks before the song
was come out like find someone else to
do the female part and
um then Halsey just randomly reconnected
and I was she ended up being the perfect
person to do that song but that song
almost didn't happen like that you know
and there was a moment of just Terror
where we had the song that we knew was
going to go off but he didn't know the
fate of it all right and then moving on
to you Alex so I know that not every
show can be a smooth ride you know from
foam Cannon malfunctions to drunken fans
spilling a cocktail on the mixer yeah
what's the worst way a music venue or
club promoter has screwed up one of your
shows oh man
oh the UK
oh yeah that's a good one uh we played
the show in uh our one of our tours at
Alexandra Palace or Ali Powell it's like
a sick venue and we agreed to like have
this like 363 camera company to come in
and capture all the content and like
live stream it which sounds like in
theory like a cool idea but then you're
adding this whole layer of just like
nonsense to an already very complicated
show another degree of difficulty yeah
like not so much for us but like our
team and it's just like extra wires and
everything everywhere and uh and I guess
we were we just started so like you know
five minutes into the show and like the
momentum's at its peak and everyone's
like you know you're feeling really
excited and everyone's having a good
time and then one of the camera people
tripped over on a wire and unplugged the
entire like I don't know I guess there's
like one power plug yeah yeah I was
gonna say like there's no there's like
the master extension cord yeah you know
and like and it was just like everything
went off like like keyboards cdjs mixer
like a power down kind of mic yeah and
it was just like you know like the first
five minutes of the show and you're just
kind of like like everyone's like huh
you know and we're like I don't know
what happened either yeah yeah lots of
and then lots of drunk people you know
like hitting the stop button yeah that
happens all the time yeah I'm usually
the drunk person
well now you're just getting back you
know that's Karma yeah coming full
circle here all right Drew so from
interviewing DJs in the past I've Heard
lots of funny stories about having to
perform at stuffy corporate Retreats
where they couldn't feel more out of
place or being called on to do a show at
like a record exec's kids birthday party
what's the most Shameless gig you guys
have ever played and then you have to
give us the bag amount in order to avoid
eating away
uh
uh last week we uh we did this uh for
like impromptu performance because
another band canceled for like 5 000 car
salesmen
oh that sounds fun no
and because we were filling in for the
other band
um they we had no like effects or like
DJ booth really and it was and they left
the lights on there was like one setting
there was no like you know we really
like it was not a day on cryo and like
effects and lasers and an LED wall
there's none of that so it was just us
up there in front of in like a
conference room in Vegas with the full
lights on trying to get people to like
dance so that was bad but I'm not going
to tell you that the bag amount so I'm
gonna go
curious
it's been in my mouth
[Music]
okay
looking good
yeah
I have a hot one
salute gives me confidence dude now yeah
all right whoa he's coming back from
work there we go champion
I like a pretty good win
yeah all right Alex we're gonna move to
you I'm trying to get something off the
plate here yeah all right which
celebrity who moonlights as a DJ is at
the top of your please stop list
oh man
[Music]
I think I mean I've been really I was
watching the Dylan Francis one last time
and I know you asked him a question and
Dylan totally [__] it up because
actually I think Shaq and Paris are like
some of the better ones that exist out
there
um I don't know I can't think of
anything but I would totally call them
out if I could think of one
does this make it does this make it
worse
uh you know here's the deal science
would say yes but my side should I go
straight to themselves no yeah yeah milk
is probably your best what are some
situations really bad ones or just in
general
oh I can't believe I'm drinking milk you
know I think like the ones that are kind
of still around like Paris or Shaq or
like Elijah Wood that's great like yeah
exactly it's just all about right right
I mean they're a couple of like stays
there are a couple like Tech founder
ones yeah like Justin Khan oh yeah
actually Steve Huffman from the Reddit
founder is a great DJ really yeah he DJ
that uh yeah Justin's brother's wedding
was hot killing it it was hot
terrible but hot there we go yeah but
thankfully we're on to the final round
here we're on to the last round and in
this one you guys can work together I
know that you guys studied music
business at Syracuse and NYU
respectively all right so I have a quiz
here three questions you get all three
questions right
I'll eat a wing off of your tray okay
but if you missed a question you guys
have to eat a wing okay do we have to
eat them in order no you know what
they're all [__] up okay
all right first question
how long does a normal copyright last
the author's life plus 30 years the
artist's life plus 70 years or 100 years
100 years
I'm gonna agree with them Final Answer
yeah I don't actually know that the
artist life plus 70 years I went to art
history school by the way yeah so that
was really on him that was my bad
you want me to just run through these
wait so now we just have to you have to
eat a wing every time we get one wrong
yeah let's do it that way why did I
bring that up oh man oh I'm sorry about
that I didn't think we'd missed that
yeah I'm sorry which quarter of the
fiscal year is considered the worst time
to put out an album the first second
third or fourth
fourth that is correct that is correct
all right we always get an argument
about that yeah about when to put out an
album but we just want to put it out and
they're like don't do it now yeah let's
do it in the fourth don't do it in the
fourth for whatever reason
that's right that's right it was like
the holiday album This is a sleeper yeah
all right last question according to a
report from The Verge the payment model
for streaming is such that a song needs
to be listened to for how long in order
to qualify for royalties 15 seconds 30
seconds one minute
I could be 15. we got one with One Wing
should we do yeah
I think third makes sense yeah
Final Answer 30 30. the answer is 30.
nice you're out of three but per the
deal All Right One Wing which one are
you gonna do I don't know you suck
I think like I'm gonna by the way like
in the regular interview like what stage
are these wings at right he's like ten
is it ten yeah
it even just you even Lube me up no very
steep ramp up rammed it in there
all right look at Drew look at Alex
Champions taking on the wings of death
dishing out the interview answers ten
toes up living to tell the tale anything
you guys would like to share with the
fans before we put you into an ice bath
[Music]
[Applause]
um
oh no it's in my throat now
I mean beautiful [__] is really [__]
hot not a joke
whoa you're going back yeah they're good
yeah yeah it looks like you I've seen
the uh I see the fire in your eye yeah
who is the pros most pro at this so far
I'll give you five names all right
David Blaine
Halle Berry
Jenna Ortega well Lord
and Michael Sarah
wow that's a great life
it's a great company yeah those are like
five episodes
like no reaction like no reaction but
you guys did great thank you thank you
just keep coming yeah like a wave I know
it just keeps building right the waves
never stop you guys did so good really
nice to meet you I appreciate having us
they're stacking more water now right
the cumulative effect is just oh why'd I
do the last one like that